hey guys I'm Brent rose tech writer and
unlicensed plastic surgeon today we're
going to be talking about wearables a
few weeks ago a study came out that kind
of blew everybody's mind this study was
conducted by researchers at the Perelman
School of Medicine in the Center for
health incentives and behavioral
economics at the University of
Pennsylvania or as you probably know
them the PS of M and the C for H I and B
II at you P what this study claimed is
that the phone in your pocket is just as
if not more accurate at tracking as the
wearables on your wrist a study like
this is catnip for journalists it spells
the death of fitness trackers and who
wouldn't want fitness trackers to die
they're ugly they're everywhere and your
friend who wears them won't shut up
about it the problem is the science
behind the study wasn't very good he
used devices there were two years old
and frankly the conclusions it drew were
really misleading let's break this down
today we're going to be doing our own
tests with all new gadgets we've got the
Withings pulse o to the basis peak the
jawbone up the move Google's Nexus 6
Apple's iPhone 6 the Garmin Phoenix 3
and fitbit's charge HR all slowly
drowning in a sea of arm hair so the
only thing that study looked at was the
accuracy of step counting on a treadmill
we're going to do the same test but in
real life I'm gonna count 1,000 steps
and here I go 1 2 3 4 5 88 99 300 1 2
99 1000 let's write everything down
three four are you kidding Wow okay so
let's see what we got here the Nexus 6
came in at only 914 steps the Withings
pulse which was in my pocket came in at
1040 seven steps the up move was 1011
steps as was the basis peak the Phoenix
on my wrist here was only off by seven
steps the iPhone came in at 995 the real
surprise here is the Fitbit which was on
my wrist came in at the most accurate
1001 steps so what we're seeing here is
that there's not a huge amount of
difference between whether or not it was
on my wrist or in my pocket whether is a
dedicated fitness tracker or whether it
was a phone they're all within a pretty
small range so this is kind of flying in
the face of what the study is saying
already that said let's see if we can
trip up the wrist worn trackers so a lot
of people think that certain activities
will trigger false positives in the step
counting so to simulate that we put all
four wearable trackers on one wrist we
decided to do about five minutes of
whittling we chose whittling because
it's a pretty good analog for some very
common activities such as peeling
carrots killing potatoes and yes
obviously what you guys are all thinking
jicama coffee thought I did a lot
of running just then 540 fall steps
611 618 722 fall steps so that was
actually pretty damning these wrist-worn
trackers were definitely subject to a
lot of false positives they thought I
took on average 622 steps while I was
just sitting here whittling so that's
really bad but here's the thing
steps counted is a really poor metric
for measuring your fitness levels anyway
it doesn't know whether you're taking
these steps quickly or slowly whether
you're walking or dancing and obviously
whittling is a serious issue and there's
another problem phones and other
accelerometer based trackers are
absolute garbage when it comes to
tracking anything that doesn't involve
steps a much more useful metric for
people is caloric burn you want to know
how many calories you're expending so
you know how much you can eat this is
where the new breed of fitness trackers
really start to set themselves apart
we're talking about the ones with
built-in heart rate monitors like the
Fitbit charge HR the basis peak the Moto
360 smartwatch and even the forthcoming
Apple watch let me show you what we mean
okay so both the Fitbit and the basis
peak are showing 74 beats per minute
right now even if these phones and the
accelerometer trackers thought that each
crunch was a single step obviously use a
lot harder than single steps so 101 99
so they know I'm working these are the
ones have no idea what's going on this
is a pretty extreme example because I'm
completely still and yet I'm working
very hard as far as the phones are
concerned and the non heartrate monitor
activity trackers I might as well be
asleep sitting on a train somewhere this
one knows however my heart rate is
already up at a hundred this one says 98
111 113 114 now couldn't Fitbit this one
again no idea what's happening obviously
biking is probably the most popular non
walking form of exercise what we're
gonna do is see how many calories I
burned at the end of a 10-minute bike
ride
most of these monitors have no idea what
I'm doing the ones that have a heart
rate monitor should show a higher
caloric burn unfortunately our two
phones don't do Clark estimates to they
flunked out right away all right my
heart's still around 140 beats per
minute I think it probably peaked around
148 let's see what the calories are so
this is exactly what we expected the
whiffing x' was way low at 50 for a
Garmin was low at 91 the jawbone was
pretty low at 163 but the Fitbit in the
basis were the two highest to 26 for the
Fitbit and 243 for the basis and that
makes a lot of sense because they were
watching my heart rate and they could
tell how hard I was working whereas
these other ones were doing it just
based on my motion so what did we learn
here today while your phone is awesome
in a lot of ways and it's less prone to
false positives and step counting step
counting isn't really that important in
the grand scheme of your overall health
the more important metric is caloric
burn and for that you got to have a
heart rate monitor so until your phone
can monitor your vitals through your
pants pocket wearables aren't going
anywhere this study was conducted by
researchers at the University a few
weeks ago a study was published in the
journal clovie Medical German the
Perelman School of Medicine and the
center for a PS of M in the C the PS of
them the PS of M in the C for why is
that so hard for me smiled blind
throughout this